[Musique]
il répète ça met les bouchées j'ai 11
ans et je suis en sixième
je vais donner le meilleur de moi
maintenant tout ce que notre temps à
l'école car ce cas le pari en kitesurf
j'ai fait tout pour atteindre les
objectifs
je suis disciplinés et rigoureux mais ce
que j'aime par dessus tout c'est d'avoir
du plaisir à jouer sur les déchets pour
sauvegarder la fête est un sujet
d'actualité et pays riches consomment
plus tôt qui polluent davantage
voyons comment la suisse un pays riche
mais petit archipel fils il a su
s'organiser pour devenir un exemple
mondial amateur de riscle à un nouveau
continent entièrement fait de déchets et
de plastique qui polluent nous aussi
bien ça vous plaît pas moi et bien à
cause de nos accueils conscien mettons
l'arrêt semaine en danger mais pour le
moment c'est les animaux marins qui
goûte les plus certains animaux marins
subissent des malformations ou la
plupart du temps il mort comment éviter
ce phénomène terrible espérons-nous de
la suisse premièrement la suisse est le
pays qui a le mieux ses déchets au monde
et c'est un des pays qui a produit le
plus la suisse dû s'organiser pour
continuer à consommer en suisse res clé
c'est gratuit mais pour jeter c'est
payant de plus ne pouvez pas utiliser
même sac de poubelle que nous nous
utilisions au québec et un sac officiel
obligatoires ici vous n'avez pas ces
sacs ne pouvait tout simplement pas
jeter ou de chez il y inclut aussi une
taxe spéciale qui varie selon la
grandeur des sacs en suisse ne pouvait
pas sortir vos déchets n'importe quoi il
ya un moment prévu venus pour la
collecte des déchets il ya même une mini
police ça sort que tous ces règles sont
respectées
sous peine d'amendés de plus de 450
dollars et c'est cette méthode qui a
influencé la population à recycler
maintenant plus de 50 % les déchets sont
recyclés ce qui créé des milliers
d'emplois dans ce domaine
en plus du papier du carton et recycler
les miom le verre et le plastique et qui
permet d'économiser
680 mille tonnes de co2 soit 280
millions de litres d'essence et avec 280
millions de litres d'essence
vous pouvez remplir 4 millions de
mercedes-benz
gl 2011 avec le reste des fruits des
légumes et du gazon coupé et pour
utiliser l'énergie
il produit suffisamment d'énergie pour
parvenir aux besoins de plus de 890
milles personnes soit quatre fois la
population de gnl et pour conclure la
population suisse est comparée à celle
du québec et leur territoire est
beaucoup plus petit qu'elle a que le nom
ce qui explique la rare 10 pour les
déchets nous le défi de commencer à
reculer davantage parce que nous on a
une grande province pour men où
déchaînés pour tous et pour les endurer
mais il ya un étude qui a été fait qui a
démontré que si nous continuons comme ça
ici 2050 il y aura plus de place et que
des poissons dans l'océan
inspirons nous de la suisse tout est
possible pour rendre notre monde
meilleur
merci et bonne cause
[Applaudissements]